[Music]
IKEA has come out with their own
television set the IKEA toughest this is
real
there's the IKEA it's called the diva
that's the correct pronunciation I don't
know I don't know it's a television that
is fully integrated into a piece of Ikea
furniture and apparently they just came
out with an ad and we got the first look
at the ad for this amazing product take
a look this is not the TV and it's not
the piece of furniture either it's all
in one and we call it ugly Abba it has
everything you could ask for in a TV
solution and it's all built-in plus
everything you require to assemble it
yourself
each up Eva comes with an illustrated in
structural manual written in Swedish and
all the essential pieces for assembling
your furniture and state-of-the-art
plasma screen television set and of
course an Allen wrench to put it all
together assembly is a snap just twist
solder then slip a magnesium oxide
coated played behind your display panel
and arrange your address electrodes
vertically inside the dielectric layer
and don't forget the floor
barb makes it all work nicer and look
you're all done now you're ready to
enjoy your new television ideas new
okhla of our television we also make
meatballs
[Applause]
don't forget the flarb know I love flarb
he does love fly